I'm Kristen Stefano you can catch me on
the bootleg Kev podcast
we got my guy Chrissy D in the building
one of my favorite comedians one of my
favorite podcasters thank you my friend
welcome sir now you are what what I've
I've just I just met you I know who you
are for a long time but I just
physically am in your presence you're an
ambiguous race I can't figure out are
you Mexican are you white are you Middle
Eastern or are you a trans I don't know
I am I am trans Caucasian Are You full
white yeah I'm Irish German and English
what so I'm just kind of like the trio
of the whitest [ __ ] possible you are the
Empire I am the I am I am I am what
Hitler was like yep yeah dude but you
can there's a vibe to you where I'm like
you could also be Latino you're gonna be
a sneaky Latina a lot because my wife's
Mexican okay my kids are Mexican right
and
um a lot of people recently have been
disappointed to find out I was white
yeah a lot of rappers once they find out
I'm white they're like yo
but your wife and I'm like what do you
want from me yeah do you still think a
white guy can [ __ ] get a hot Latin
woman
dude my wife's Puerto Rican that's what
I mean yeah bro but I don't look Latino
at all so you're you're you're certainly
white like it's very clear to me that
like at least my girl she knew she was
going in white your girl could have been
like I thought he was Mexican but now
unfortunately too late it's too late but
it's too late because you're too late
you already dropped that guy
the Empire day yeah that's what it is
it's a good dick
yeah
when I first when I first was sleeping
with my girl like uh you know I had to
impress her so I would I got the the
honey pack from the gas station yes you
know what I mean nice beautiful first
month I was just I was on HGH yeah dude
yeah and then I know I always I always
like to go the first couple of weeks
with a new girl just sex with the lights
off lights off yeah because it's just
you know I like at least I get them
hooked and then it's just a full letdown
because then the lights go on and you're
like yeah because I'm one of those guys
like you know you know people always
like oh you [ __ ] you must be jacked
but then I take my shirt off my tits go
like this you know like I always have a
crumb in my belly button my dick has a
couple of warts on it and it's just one
of those things where you get them
hooked they fall in love and then they
just start to see pastors are you
circumcised fully served okay yeah but
one of my camera guys yesterday was
telling us
which sounds like a name for a [ __ ] he's
got he's like we were all talking about
like how we were somehow we were in a
van in New York talking about our dicks
it happened and uh I was like yeah two
out of the four people were not
circumcised and I was like that's
[ __ ] gross right and then I was like
yeah no I'm circumcised but I'm like 75
circumcised okay what does that mean he
said that like they cut his dick and
then they like reattached a part of the
skin humor so part of the skin is
connected to the head and then he
started to pull up like pictures of
other dicks that look like his dick and
I was like bro ugh that's a rough
[ __ ] go for a young lady that's gotta
look at that mutilated [ __ ] meat
finger down there honestly even when I'm
watching porn
it doesn't matter how hot the girl is if
the guy's uncircumcised I'm like gross
can't do it next video what percentage
of gay does it make me that I have to
have a nice dick in the video here's the
thing here's what I'm about to tell you
right now backed by science I just
watched this was maybe a few months ago
I just watched a neuroscientist talk
about that men straight men 99 of the
time will fast forward or go to the next
porn video if the man's penis isn't big
because what excites a man a man's
sexual part of the brain are tits and a
dick that's what it wants to you want to
see big breasts and a big dick because
the subcon the little dick
subconsciously makes the man feel
insecure because they start to think
about their own size and it takes them
out of it they want big big huge dick
right with big boobs so hypothetically
the straight man would have the highest
climax off a transgender [ __ ] porn
that's the neuroscientist that's the
neuroscientist that I hired
um give give that lecture no that's the
neuroscientist that was backed by
science dude so it's weird you bring
that up that wait wait wait so
hypothetically a straight this is this
is real this is backed by science
this I saw a TED Talk of I was also an
event with my friends and I was like
let's look up Ted Talks on that can
verify that we're not gay because we
like females so we looked into it and
this is true you can YouTube this
it literally the the scientists said
yeah they did a whole study you know in
Sweden or one of those crazy Freaky
Deaky countries right where they were
like that men got most excited by a big
penis and a big pair of boobs right
because that in in the core of the brain
you want the big boobs obviously you
want you know we know and why and and do
you know why actually big boobs why
where why we're attracted to big boobs
and a big butt do you know the
scientific reason for that I don't I
didn't know there was one I mean I enjoy
nice big breasts but I I would probably
fancy myself and ask guy but you know I
like both okay here's here's what it is
so the reason why you even asked the
reason why scientists say you like men
we like big boobs and a big butt wide
hips is the boobs one is because what
we're subconsciously Neanderthal brings
seeing baby has milk our babies will
have milk to feed off big breasts right
and comfortable pillow to lay on yeah no
no no butt hips yeah wide birthing Canal
gives us subconsciously our chance our
baby's chance the best chance of
survival so we associate the butt with
the hips that's the reason why and
that's also the reason why women like
this all makes sense big guys why they
like attracted to a taller guys because
in her safety she's saying he can guard
me from animals he can go out and Hunt
he can go out and hunt and that's also
why men are attracted to more physical
attributes and beauty and women aren't
because what a woman needs is a man who
all they really care about is if they're
smart enough because you have to again
we live in a different world now but
this is Neanderthal brain that we still
have you know are connected to the man's
has to be smarter that's why they're
less about uh physical qualities because
you have to be cunning to go out and
hunt and find food and right right where
the woman is not going out and doing
that so we don't care if she's smart or
not we just say dumb big old titties
for our baby's breast milk and the big
[ __ ] and a big [ __ ] and a nice and a
nice uh nice wide birthing Canal that's
what it is if Kim Kardashian had a [ __ ]
I'd be in
have you seen have you seen uh my wife
follows this makeup artist
um Nikita dragon
she's an Asian uh makeup influencer but
she's she's trans right okay but like
[ __ ] smoking okay but it's like it's
almost like crazy yes you know what I
did actually my girl told me to look
into Nikita dragon and I did and we
reached out to do her podcast or if I
could go on hers it should come of mine
and she I believe her reps just sent a
one-word answer which was no yeah that's
where I know her hard no hard no and I'm
like well I'm still jerking off to you
so can't stop me from doing that yeah I
always tell my friends I'm like yo I
can't watch lesbian porn no there's
nothing in lesbian porn for me nothing
there's nothing because I like to at
least feel like I'm the the dude that's
you know [ __ ] yes yeah and I honestly
I try to come I come like time I come
shot with the guys come shot yes yeah
yeah I
that's the strategy that's what I like
and I also like
an up close and personal [ __ ] I like
a [ __ ] I don't like you know if
you're eating a girl I don't care nobody
wants to see a guy at a chick out let me
see your wet [ __ ] dude
how many people you think turn this
podcast off or they're not going to get
the gold especially my my audience
they're like yo what the [ __ ] hey yo yo
he's suspect pause pause your man's wild
sucks
oh man well welcome thank you that was a
great way to kick things off there it is
um for people who don't know you how did
you because did you kind of um
give us kind of a rundown on how you
kind of started to get your Buzz going
in the in the comedy scene was it the
Opie and Anthony show Opie and Anthony
was was definitely big for me I started
stand up in 2009 2010. okay and then you
know it's interesting like I went that
route of you know I got on Guy Code Guy
Code and girl code which was was big
like Big Show by the way Shoals was on
there as well Charlemagne bro Schultz
Charlemagne uh um Akash there's like so
many people that came from that yeah man
uh uh Aquafina like all these people
um came out of it Nicole buyer and
there's like literally if you look it's
like wow little Duvall you're like all
these people on Guy Code and girl code
and really nobody the biggest one was
Charlemagne Charlemagne and Duvall were
you know pretty pretty famous but of
course other than that
um nobody really had a career it was
like all our our starting off points
Pete Davidson so so it's like um um you
know we did that show and that listen
that definitely got us to a point got us
in the clubs got us known but it still
didn't get you to like you still weren't
like we weren't none of us were really
selling tickets or or you know on the
road because that's really the barometer
of a comic you could be on this TV show
on that TV show do that but can you sell
tickets because selling tickets is it's
not only it's not only to to other
Comics but also just as a world thing
it's like there's no smoke and mirrors
with ticket sales there's a lot of smoke
and mirrors with television you could be
on a hit oh I got a CBS show I got it
this show no one gives a [ __ ] about you
but guess what nobody knows who you are
nobody's nobody cares to purchase a
ticket but there's no because because
you could make you know the New York
Post or whomever could write an article
about anyone saying that the next big
whatever and it's like it's [ __ ] if
no one's at your shows yeah that if the
people come that's how you know so the
people really weren't coming until
really I started to do podcasting and
the internet and I had to kind of fail
uh in television to learn that because I
had a I had a I have my daughter's seven
now she was about six months old at the
time I had a a sitcom with CBS a pilot
filmed the whole thing you know I met
dull people like Chaz commentary from
Bronx Tale um uh he played my father in
the show Diane Guerrero played my love
interest from Orange is the New Black
and and a bunch of other stuff and uh
and then I thought I was gonna be you
know the next Ray Romano or the CBS was
telling me you're going to be this and
that and then the show didn't go just
failed did not did not go spend a year
in my life put everything I had until it
was going back and forth to La time away
from my family
and then you know missed moments with my
daughter's life and I was like oh but
this will be good we'll move to LA
because I was following this you know
route of the blueprint yeah Seinfeld
nine right right right Bill Cosby all
these guys and um
and it didn't go and I said well [ __ ]
now I got a daughter A young daughter
you know that I have a life here I got I
got a girl I have a stepson I was like I
need to make money so I said I made a
deal with myself when it when it didn't
go I said um I said I'm not going to
allow myself ever again in my career to
not be in control I'm never gonna put my
fate of my career and my family someone
else's hands in someone else's hands the
only people I will give it to is the
audience is the fan so I said find a way
to give your put your career in the
hands of your fans and that's when I
turn to the internet and podcasting and
it's really it was going good going good
and then it's weird like that when the
pandemic happened you know a lot of
people kind of career life got put on
pause but that's when my career like got
to the next level yeah because everybody
the whole world just sitting in front of
computer same thing with Schultz Schultz
exploded in the pandemic definitely so
it's it's one of those things where I
still and I live by that now and now I
am going to do some some TV stuff but
it's all on my own terms I'm like yo I
don't want to go to La I don't want I
want to do a whole if I'm going to do TV
it's got to be out of New York because
now I have the the the power because
because my fans right because my career
is in the hands of my fans now my
tickets are sold now we add shows now
you know I have a podcast and a patreon
and everything is being controlled
through my way so now I can tell you
know now I can dictate my own terms
where a lot of times with TV you can't
they'll the corporate person will say
well you can't do this because uh you
know we they have all the bargaining
chips but now I can say well listen if
we don't do it my way no problem I don't
I find another guy yeah it's and and
it's very respectful but it's like
there's no reason I need to do your show
other I have everything I'm only going
to do what I want to do that's a great
position to be in inline yeah I sit on
my couch or or or our studio very close
to my house say exactly what I want to
the fans that want to hear it they come
and buy tickets to my show and we have a
happy little family and to be honest
with you and I'm fine with this it's
like even somebody like my mother would
be like oh why don't you want to do this
show at that show because even she
doesn't understand like I lose money
doing that so not only is it Freedom uh
you know comedically which is the most
important but financially it's like you
know I make way more money doing it my
way sitting on my couch being I don't
miss a I barely miss any events in my
daughter's life unless I'm on the road
because I'm like I don't I'm not gonna
go away and do things I don't there's
time is time is so much more valuable to
me than money it's the greatest currency
it is the greatest currency I don't need
you know I think about money in a diff
very diff now I got two kids three
daughters and a stepson so now I'm like
yo I I I just don't I flat like I just
turned down a movie yesterday that would
take me to La for six weeks and I'm like
it was with a comedy hero of mine
um you know the money was okay uh but I
was like it's just not worth it man I I
I'll do that I'll hopefully that
opportunity similar opportunity is there
20 years from now when I'm older and my
kids don't want to hang out with me
anyway you know they're in college and I
but right now at this time I don't want
to miss anything in their life so I'm
very focused on hey I'm only going to do
things that keep me close to home now
listen I I gotta you know when I go on
the road and yeah you got a tour you
gotta I got a tour but it's but it's
minimal time it's like I get a weekend I
get to a city Thursday I'm home Sunday
morning it's not like eight weeks away
I'll never do that you know
um so yeah so so I think that was the
big big thing that changed in my career
was my mindset of I will only put my
career in the hands of my fans I will
not I will and I also even on the TV
shows I do it's like listen if you don't
like the way I'm I understand you can't
say certain words on television I get
that but if you're gonna
dumb down my comedy to a point that I'm
not happy not me anymore I'm off the
show you can sue me I mean I don't care
you know hey what up y'all bootleg Kev
gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our newest sponsor man shout out
to the homies at hardean Las Vegas
that's right the number one dispensary
in the whole state of Nevada let alone
in the whole [ __ ] country so many
choices of Premium cannabis ladies and
gentlemen it is like how can I put this
you walk into it you go to Jardine in
Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sense
you'll be like yo bootleg have sent me
they're gonna take care of you at
hardean when I say selection I mean
selection of the best premium cannabis
in the world the best dispensary there's
a reason why hardeen is world famous
follow them right now Harding underscore
Las Vegas go to their website
hardinglasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview most
people would take the movie with their
comedic hero
listen for me I just thought about it
right and I was just like can you say
who it is Kevin Hart no no no that was
uh Bill bear okay oh oh [ __ ] yeah and
and and and and and and you know it was
one of those things where I was like yo
like I I is that worth six weeks away
from my kids is that worth missing
six-track practices a birthday uh um you
know um uh is it worth uh uh three movie
Nights is it is it is it worth all that
and I was like you know we're not
struggling financially right now or
anything we want and I and you know
what's great you know what's the best
part about all this too is I can have
say what I want right to my fans who
care have some Financial Freedom and
flexibility that my fans give me and the
best part is I also have my anonymity
when I walk down the street I get
noticed maybe two or three times but
it's a beautiful thing but but it's like
but even if I did do even if I said
something out of context on a tweet
right nobody no one's coming for you
that's hard they'd be like oh what does
he have a [ __ ] podcast where he sits
down with TT Jerry Chrissy cast They
Don't they'd be like this is not big
enough now if you get in a movie if you
get on a big taste now they have [ __ ] to
take from you now but if you don't give
them that then what do they have to take
they had something where they were on
your ass recently uh you would on Tick
Tock yeah was it like a Latin joke or
something I don't think I think I think
people took out of context and they
don't realize you're married to a Latin
woman yeah so that but it's interesting
so that happened you know the Mexican
Community was coming after me right and
I understood the wording of that joke
because basically what I was trying to
say was it's basically it was a whole
made-up scenario so what I was trying to
say was is that TT Jerry who if you
don't know she's on my podcast she's a
transgender Latina woman did 20 years in
prison you know Puerto Rican like she's
like you know it's it's it's my wife's
uncle and she's actually my kids
godmother now and you know whatever
she's my family and so so we you know
say wild [ __ ] on the Pod together but we
were saying that there was a guy was
fixing my uh a friend family friend was
fixing an air conditioner unit in my in
my uh attic and his foot went through
the ceiling right so I was like and he
said he was like he was like oh [ __ ] he
goes I'm sorry I was like yeah whatever
just patch it up and then and then he
goes and then he goes he was like he's
Spanish but he was like oh I don't have
my papers I don't have my papers and
then like so we were just like joking
around like that and all laughing so
then I went to the podcast the next day
and that's what it is like you take
scenarios like that and you make bits
and you make yeah that's even on a
podcast people like hey what you said
about X Y and Z that you know sometimes
my family called me like that's not true
right I'm not this isn't therapy right
we're doing a show yeah so we're
entertaining people so what happened was
they said on the podcast I said oh you
know like a a Mexican uh worker fell
through my ceiling yesterday and I was
like you know I was like uh T you know
he said that his neck hurt and then TT
Jerry went up there and was like I said
that he fell through this what I meant
to say was he fell through the ceiling
and then 20 minutes later all of a
sudden he said his neck hurt and then TT
Jerry went up the stairs like oh your
neck hurt where's your paper so then he
was like I don't have papers and he was
like trabajo like that so but the way
the tick tock came out was I didn't say
the 20 minute part and I just did a word
right so it sounded like especially if
you don't know me it sounds like this
white guy is here talking about the
Latino community and and all the and it
got to the point where like people are
like somebody goes we found the worker
we're gonna we're gonna leave we found
him some like famous Mexican-American
attorney or I guess famous on tick tock
like we message me they're like we found
the worker we are going to represent him
for free or as his grants I was like the
worker is literally a dummy from Staten
Island who's a family friend like what
there's
no worker so I texted his name is
Anthony I was like did anybody reach out
to he was like I don't even have a cell
phone like you know like so like it's
just like stupid and then these people
attack so but then it's interesting
because it's just a microcosm like
social media it's just a microcosm
people because you think they're like oh
people are like sending me like death
threats right and then I did shows
coincidentally I think three weeks later
in um in the not the Irvine uh was yeah
it was the Irvine Improv yeah which is a
huge Mexican of course community in
North Korea bro the the producer I'm
sorry the manager of the club you know
is beautiful sold out shows thank you to
people of Irvine of course you know it's
like all the shows put together it's
like 3 000 tickets it's like a big ass
venue six six six shows 500 people each
show he told me he was like other than
Felipe Esparza who's a huge Mexican L.A
because you have the most Mexican fans
I've ever seen in this venue and all of
them love none of them even none of them
even saw that Tick Tock or barely any of
them did and the ones that did were like
like yo it's [ __ ] hilarious let's
think about the internet it's like you
can't take it too serious because it's
always the really loud minority and like
you always think in your head everybody
saw this when really not that many
people in your real life for fans really
actually give a [ __ ] or yeah because you
have to also understand you have to
understand the mindset of someone on
social media for you to even
both ways and listen it's all good I I
you know will appreciate it like
whatever but for you to comment
negatively on someone's Instagram or
Tick Tock publicly or positively it's a
little bit like most people don't give a
[ __ ] at all right most people are like
yeah I just move on with my [ __ ] like I
would comment on something you because
we know each other but for random people
to comment or send you DMS positive or
negative is a little like it's just
strange and most most people most people
don't care most people didn't even see
that Tick Tock or they did they didn't
give a [ __ ] and they bought a ticket
because they like me from other things
or they didn't buy a ticket because they
don't like me forever so the people that
get so wrapped up so actually a step
that I've taken is and I understand you
know not everyone can do this I get it
to be in a fortunate position but I have
now given the keys to my all my social
media Instagram Tick Tock Twitter
everything to someone else to a a guy
who works for my management company I
know him very well he has the passwords
to everything I purposely told him do
not give I don't want to know I don't
want to have access into my own social
media you you know if somebody like you
reached out and he was like yo and then
he'll send it to me about giving my
number tell them to text me we'll do
things like that but I'm like I don't
want to know because it is a thing a lot
of people talk about
negative comments and how it messes with
your brain chemistry 100 accurate so do
positive ones positive ones take you out
into these egotistical state where you
aren't who you really are so I said you
know what I don't need it anymore it's
built up to me where it's comfortable
like you know whatever I however many
you know hundreds thousands are on there
it's comfortable enough for me it's a
ticket selling apparatus for me I I tell
my guy what to post every day give him
the video tell him the caption so it is
my writing and my work of course but I
don't have any I don't know who's saying
who's the image who's commenting even
after shows there would be a thing where
I would be paralyzed after shows you you
have a good show go check the 30 50 100
DMS girls guys I want to hang out I want
to take you to bar and I'd be oh my God
you almost have you know sometimes too
many options it's too much choices not
Freedom if you're in prison with too
many choices that's that's a thing where
it's like I I felt like the less I had
the less people that have access to me
the Freer I am so I was like now the
only people that have access to me is if
you have my number or my email if you're
a personal friend or family member then
we can talk other than that there's a
layer there's someone a buffer in front
and bro it's made everything in my life
so much better from from from
relationship with my girl relationship
with my kids my body I've lost like 25
pounds fasting working out because I'm
not I'm not sucked in you're not stuck
on the phone I'm not sucked into the
toxicity of it even you know yes yes
women you know all that stuff you know
because sex is an addiction like
anything else that gets you in trouble
of course uh comparison you know my one
of my favorite quotes I just did a video
about it from Teddy Roosevelt who says
oh my fault these guys crying uh one one
of my favorite quotes from uh Teddy
Roosevelt is um is a comparison is the
thief of Joy oh yeah it's the worst yeah
so so I don't compare myself to my peers
I don't know what my peers are doing I'm
happy for whatever they're doing I only
I compare me to me even on social media
some don't you compare you to you and
that's not good either you'll look at a
picture or video of yourself from 10
months ago and be like why don't why
don't I look like that anymore or I was
more popping back then it's all [ __ ]
yeah so I just stay for me I've made a
decision I only care I also don't want
someone on the other side of the world
to influence my day I don't they don't
know me I don't know them so I made
another choice where I was like I'm only
going to deal with the opinions of the
people in the room with me or my friends
and family those people I would care
about if I'm being a physical process or
a friend but some other person writing
something on YouTube or Instagram I
don't give it I don't give it my head
space anymore some people are strong
enough to say well I just won't look I
wasn't I had to just look myself in the
mirror and say you're you're too much of
a of a [ __ ] Chris right you need to get
rid of it so I did just I didn't delete
it because I you know again it's a
ticket selling out it's part of your but
I don't have any access to it so like if
you DM people in my life who you know
communicating with who do have my number
like yo are you mad at me you don't
respond to my DMs anymore I'm like bro
you got to text me I don't have any
information I don't I don't even have a
way into that anymore and um you know I
know that you know that not everybody
has to do that but for me I've only seen
positive change uh since I've gotten
less like less on social media and more
just focusing on on the people in front
of me yeah the screen time thing when
you look at your screen time it's kind
of like a rude awakening where you're
like
[ __ ] I said how much time looking at
this [ __ ] thing yeah yeah it's crazy
yeah and you know it's weird it's
because it's like you know my head is up
more
um I'm looking around more you know I
there's been times where
you know I would even see somebody's you
know a peer of mines a great video that
that they posted or whatever and I'm
like I'll call my guy right away like yo
we got to make something we like you
know and then that making something yeah
maybe would have pushed things a little
further or maybe not but in order to
make that I then would have to skip out
on dinner with my family where now I do
my work for the day I set my time and
then it's done and then I and then
whatever happens happens like whatever
it may be may be because I'm like you
know you only get one spin around this
planet so I'm like I'm like I don't
wanna the thing that I know you'll never
get back is time and especially you know
for those of us who have children I'm
like I'm never gonna get they'll never
be little again there will be a time
where they don't they don't want us yeah
they're going to be like you're gross Go
away You're cringy yeah and I'm like
listen you got hot friends babe you know
like they're they're 19 right bring them
over yeah no no no but but but
um so right now though I mean listen and
of course it's like you know you got to
work I'm happy to work my my career
makes me happy you know you got you we
have to be happy first of course the
rest of our family's happy but I right
now I'm just like yeah man like I uh you
know I pick and choose what what it is I
want to do and and uh but the getting
off social media
um has helped me like tremendously I
genuinely in my heart believe that
whatever it is 50 years from now social
media will be looked at as toxic and
cancerous as smoking cigarettes were
back in the day like I think it's I
think it's a similar thing it's a
different thing it's not causing lung
cancer right but it is causing uh a
decay in society and I would have lost
the depression depression this I cannot
I would I would imagine I would be
willing to bet everything that suicide
rates being as high as they have ours is
directly linked to social media and I
think that the people at the social
media companies know that and I think
that it's you know it's it's an
algorithm it's they're feeding on our
our um social capabilities is it's money
to them so they they're they're they're
gambling on you know what we're gonna
are you know predicting our moves and
making money off it so I get it but I
don't want to be a part of it anymore
you know or as little about that's dope
man yeah that's right that's what I kill
myself tonight
just blow my head off Jesus it's just yo
let me uh because so you're a white man
who's with a Puerto Rican language I'm a
biological white male yes so am I talk
to I don't have a lot of people who I
can relate to go into the Latin the
Latino my wife's side of the families
yes family events parties and being the
only white guy there yes and like you're
kind of like Kevin yeah it's it's here's
the thing the it's one of those things
where you know a lot of times the family
speaking Spanish most of the time
including my seven-year-old daughter
we'll just start talking to me sometimes
in Spanish and I'm like did you just
have a stroke I don't know what you're
saying at all
um and and uh and you know getting used
to the culture and the food
um you know the first time
the first time I ever had uh um paella
um uh yes and yeah that and and um and
uh what's uh Bernie the the the pork
that was I mean I loved it delicious but
I genuinely [ __ ] blood and because my
Germanic GI system was like what did you
just do did you just we've never seen
this we can't process it we need to
bleed what is this we need to bleed but
it's the food is so good that you just
go back for more and I gotta be honest
man I love the Latino culture so much
always happy yeah you know always
vibrant dancing you know best food hard
food tits I love it yeah you know uh
everybody you know the the most
beautiful women in the world to me are
like literally I would say the most
beautiful women and men my girls family
are just the hottest people
either gender I've ever they even have
hot pets I'm like dude I want to [ __ ]
your dog
come here do they ever what up y'all we
gotta stop the interview real quick tell
you about our good friends at my bookie
that's right man my bookie is where you
want to get this money and uh enjoy uh
being a
degenerate like myself and it's the best
time of the year to be a degenerate
because NFL season is uh obviously we
are in the midst of a crazy NFL season
NBA season just started World Series is
going down and you can get your bets in
right now go to my bookie and sign up
for a new account using the promo code
bootleg that's
b-o-o-t-l-e-g you sign up right now they
will match your first deposit that's
right put in a thousand oh they'll give
you another thousand to gamble with
that's free money free money to gamble
with let's get in on this action man NFL
season I'm loving this part of the year
so much good just everything to bet on
football basketball [ __ ] UFC uh NFL
baseball whatever now is the best time
to get your gamble on so go sign up for
a new account at mybookie use that promo
code bootleg and double your deposit
let's get back to the interview
obviously like like Latins are pretty
conservative uh do any of your girl's
family ever seen your comedy and like
hit her up about and be like yo what's
wrong with it like oh yeah yeah well
that see it's it you know that see
that's it it's a weird well because you
you're obviously heavily in the music
game it's an interesting thing Society
Comics talk about this and I think about
this a lot it's like a comic right will
get scrutinized for word you know my
this joke or that joke right you know
Kevin Hart uh a home of full tweet can't
holds the Oscars whatever but then on
that same show they have like Eminem on
who does rap lyrics about killing his
ex-wife and put it in a truck and raping
his mind so you're like how come rap
gets a pass and and Comics don't it's a
it's this thing in society that no one
can really explain and I think that it's
interesting like you know like like
sometimes I feel like you know as as a
white guy sometimes I'm like yo man
especially in this like if I say
anything oh homophobe you're a racist
and I'm like yo honestly the most
homophobic easiest people I've ever met
my life are not white dude they are so
Latino and black some of the Latino and
black people I've met I'm like what are
you a Nazi you can't say that you know
but it's true you're so right no it's
like I'm like but I'm the [ __ ] bad
guy I'm like holy [ __ ] like you can't
you can't give us homophobic people in
my life are definitely people of color
yeah 100 dude some of the [ __ ] that I've
heard at Family barbecues on my girls
side I'm like I literally I want to call
my Senator I like I'm like I'm gonna I'm
contacting the police
but you know I'm the one with [ __ ]
Hitler head so I'd be in trouble for it
but but I'm like but I'm like yo but it
it's one of those things where but see
that's the thing that's the thing I I
think too is is you know getting you
know dating outside your race is you
realize you know yes racism race I
understand that but it's it's really
tribalism that's what it is it's like
people want to just they feel safe with
people that look like that right sound
like them and come through the same
struggles as them so that's why you know
you'll have I believe like you know say
like you know sometimes you'll have like
Latino people that like say the N word
and you'll have a white person like well
how come they can say the n-word and I
can it's like well because the Latino
and black struggle is very similar in
this country where the white struggle is
different so that's why so it's a
tribalism they've become a tribe but
they've said hey this is always a white
person that's that's mad about it always
yeah yeah like a white lady yes 37 yeah
got a few cats yeah well I like it's
funny like as it like I guess because
i'm you know heavily in the Latino
culture I always think that too I'm like
why do I people care I'm like just dude
I want to tell white people just shut
the [ __ ] up it's that guilt [ __ ] yeah
dude it's not your job to police
everybody's feelings I'm like just shut
up you're not the bar of what what's
offensive
like if if a white person is more
offended than the person the joke's
actually about like it's probably a good
joke yeah it's it's it's one of the you
know it's funny I was in and uh and it's
crazy and I didn't make I didn't say
anything but I was about to like make
like a bit about it so so in in the room
so literally I was in you know Swag
right sweat great friends sway is like I
hosted a show in 2014 on MTV with sway I
was because nobody watched it but it was
called off the bat but anyway sway
taught me so much knowledge about like
hosting and showing being on camera and
just being in this world sway is like I
love sway I think he might be the father
of my youngest kid and and I love it
please you know she misses you
um so so sway sway is the best but I
remember I was in Sway in the Morning
yeah you know as a guest on on his
serious show with the whole Jesse
Smollett oh thing broke right yeah and I
was in there white guy you know you know
all black cast all better bees in there
another B everybody and they're they're
just letting Tracy's reading it and
she's like you know and it's horrible
and it's like the [ __ ] energy in
there it's like oh [ __ ] and then they
say they're like you know uh um Jesse
Smollett was was you know attacked
beaten by two white uh you know that
they were saying at the time two white
men
um and they were like you know you know
they they threw acid at him and a noose
and they said you you must be you're
that you're that guy from Empire you
know what uh whatever you're like those
rednecks watch Empire you're that guy
from Empire and so at that point I was
about to say I don't think that's real
because no white people watch Empire and
uh and then and I didn't say it and if I
would have said it then it would I would
have been like thrown out and
scrutinized but literally I would have
been right but you would have been
living right because when I heard that
story I was like everything everything
checks out but not that yeah because my
comic mind was like anybody with a Maga
hats and not watching Empire yeah I was
like this is a hoax but you know it was
funny like and sometimes I'm like yo I
should have just did The Joke Man I'm a
comic but then I was like yo I love
story and that might have cost you your
friendship for a few months you did it
yeah exactly would have caused my
friendship for about six months and I'm
like come on come on you know I was
right yeah yeah but but but it was one
of those things where I remember that
moment being like yo
um uh but but yeah man I think too with
comedy you know the beautiful thing
about being a comic is my shows man I
got it the thing one of the things I'm
most proud of it's very culturally
diverse man it's like a community
college when you come to my show
everybody's out there all different
religions races it's it's dope so um
because I think you know comedy is one
of those things where it's like we just
go up there confident with the jokes
Comedy is not supposed like when people
get mad at Comics they're such [ __ ]
nerds because it's like the comic is the
member of society it's supposed to say
the thing they're supposed to say things
nobody else could say because it's an
outlet that's why we do it in dark dingy
basements I'm not telling you to go tell
your friends at the water cooler when
they [ __ ] dummy yeah but you know
like so so I think though for the most
part too at least with Comics you know
if it's just words actions are you know
uh you know you do some criminal [ __ ]
that's the eyes of the law but comics
with words I think it's happening less
and less with the quote unquote cancel
stuff because it's like yo we're coming
in my opinion you cannot be funny and
hateful like
you're one of the other like you know
Hitler wasn't funny because all hate so
it's like you if you're funny and and
the joke comes off wrong that's why
comedy is subjective it may not be for
you that's fine right it's intent based
it's like what was your intent with this
yeah it wasn't to like be hateful or to
be yeah or hurt feelings it was to make
light of something everyone's thinking
about anyway yeah because you gotta
understand too man like any big Uprising
you know I love hearing some big history
fan you cannot you know like sign
Islands comics and artists you can't do
that because I'm telling you when it
comes down to it like you know in the
Holocaust you know they killed the
artist in comic they killed them first
because they don't want you they don't
these regime doesn't want people talking
and open you know dialogue like we have
what we have in this country right now
is such a beautiful thing you can you
can we can have differences of opinions
you know we all that stuff you know like
like this discourse that's like fine but
this these groups of people that wanna
you know like you know they'll say
silence is violence unless I speak up
and say what you don't want me to say
then you try to silence me so it the
premise of it doesn't make any sense to
me it never did right so I'm like so I'm
like as a comic I'm like yo we gotta all
just keep talking about whatever it is
you want to talk about uh because you
need us you know just like we need
musicians and and all that and the
people try to silence like I don't know
why at times politicians you know will
get you know Comics will get treated
like politicians and politicians will
get treated like Comics like as a comic
that's true you know know it it's I mean
think about the Trump [ __ ] he got the
pass like he was a comedian for so much
of the [ __ ] he said yeah and then
there'll be comedians around that same
time that Kevin Hart thing had yeah
where it's like wait which one is which
yeah like like it's almost like this
this little like defect in society where
it's like what you're attacking like the
wrong people man like I'm a comic I'm
not I'm not trying I don't have anything
to do with Congress like you know but
but the people who had something to do
with Congress like you said the the free
pass so it's just been an interesting
thing but that's why but I think you
know again turning to an audience and a
fan base that just likes what I do it's
almost like well you know I think this
idea of being generically famous isn't
realistic anymore like you're not good
with too much of a niche Society now I
think the same with music and and comedy
and movies it's like you know it's it's
only for a certain group of people but
go for that I mean you know now these
movies that win you know Oscars mostly
have never seen them or we don't know
you know you you you don't know yeah
they'll announce the best pictures of
the year and I'm like I've never because
it's because it's not for us it's for
that that Niche right right so so so
it's an interesting um interesting thing
uh how did you end up linking up with
I'm a huge Impractical Jokers fan the
best so me and my son's like favorite
show since like season one since he was
like I remember watching Impractical
Jokers when my kid was like eight and
now he's like 17. yeah I've seen
probably every episode yeah uh and when
Sal started doing the podcast thing I
loved it and yeah um you guys obviously
have a great Dynamic how did you guys
link up so we started hey babe
um about two years ago we were been so
Sal you know Impractical Jokers was huge
and then Sal so Sal used to run a show
at this place on Staten Island called
cargo where he was not dude he hadn't
even made impractical jokes that he was
literally the bar owner and bartender
that ran a comedy show okay and all us
Comics would come to his comedy show and
be like yo this guy is great and then
all of a sudden I'm nowhere once they
were like is that the guy that owns car
Largo he has a TV show like you know you
know he did comedy yeah yeah and then
and then and then he comes out obviously
hit show uh same with me I mean my kids
are too young but I watched that show
and die laughing I would watch oh my God
it's well I mean it's because a lot of
times like you know we of course we
always support our friends and comedy
they got a Netflix show or whatever and
we watch it you know to give them the
views and whatever we can help but
Impractical Jokers is like I genuinely
watch it because I'm like this makes me
feel better about my day when I can just
laugh at and you can watch it with
anybody yeah yeah you know it's not like
back in the day when I was like in high
school like I couldn't watch Jackass
with my parents no no but I can watch
Impractical Jokers yeah yeah yeah that's
mostly who I watch it with my parents
and you know we get along but but Sal in
2014 uh I was doing a show at at
Caroline's and he came
um and and you know we we we we knew
each other just through social media but
then we started to like actually become
friends and we we hung would hang out
all the time you know he would always
throw a big Super Bowl party at his
house and see him all the time and then
he started doing stand up you know and
then as he started would stand up we
started I started seeing about the clubs
and you know he's become like this great
stand-up now and and um and then uh two
years ago uh we were just like you know
pandemic happened we're like yo we we
hang out like every weekend and just
talk [ __ ] for six hours and die laughing
why don't we just make this a pod yeah I
need you to make this a pod yeah and
then we just did it you know found the
place did it and and you know and now it
literally doing hey babe you know
Chrissy chaos I I love doing but you
know it's on me it's it's like it's
usually just me or or or you know a lot
of times you don't have a guess and and
I love doing it I have fun but it's a
lot of work where hey babe is literally
just we go in there with most the time
99 of the time no plan other than hey
we're gonna catch up
on camera on camera and that's what it
is so so that that's that literally that
podcast literally is salinized
friendship since 2014 just on display
that that's all it is when Joe leaves
the show do the fans like start this uh
this this campaign it may be the fourth
guy I got so many messages my agent got
it was constant like Chris Chris and
then I spoke to Sal about it and I said
to Sal I said the beauty of and he of
course agreed and they you know the the
plan that they have now is working where
they get like Pokemon yeah that Method
Man and that that works beautiful
because the the the the thing is like
you know these these networks would try
to recreate Impractical Jokers and
because it was such a mega hit the
reason why it was a mega hit is because
their friendship started at 14 years old
right so don't throw someone like me in
or another one of you know our comedy
peers I'm not friends and expect the
same chemistry 30 years of chemistry
that cannot be duplicated by anyone else
unless there's four group of friends
that have that mindset data so you can't
just reproduce that that is their
friendship on display that I'm not a
part of so it's like the way they're
doing it now is just to have a outside
guy in just once in a while that's cool
it's the smart that's cool I hope Joe
ends up coming coming back he's so big
on Tick Tock I know dude he's the best
on tickets he's the best team yeah Joe
Joe is I mean he he was my favorite yeah
yeah that was a [ __ ] Maniac you know
what's crazy too about you know being
with Sal because I I used to open for
Sal yeah I would open for Sal a lot
um uh over the last uh few years but you
know now now we both do our own
headlining things but but but Sal you
know when I would be with him it's crazy
how like you know he would have all his
fans like it almost feels like all four
of them each have the same amount of
fans but they're all different groups of
people like you got the cube fans you
got the the mer fans you got the sound
fans you got the Joe fans they all
collectively love all four of them but
it's like you know 10 million people
love Sal 10 love Joe 10 left it's like a
wild thing how like their their Fame is
literally split four ways evenly it's
also like it's pretty wild that like
somehow they have had the biggest comedy
series I I don't know it feels like in a
long time it it is this is a fact in the
top five biggest comedy shows of all
time including Seinfeld they have
they're the the arena tours the crews
and somehow I feel like they don't get
the respect or or the like uh
recognition that they deserve yeah it's
it's one of I think it's because like
what I noticed like when people come up
to sell in the airport and all that
first of all you know he gets mobbed I
like that and and and but he gets mobbed
in a way that because they and they are
but because on the show especially they
do such an amazing job of coming off
like we're just four regular guys like
yours like you would just come up to Sal
and be like I love you man is this a
joke or touch you or whatever because
like you're just one of the kids
because there's a wall you're like no
it's a movie story you know or the rock
or something like that where sound
you're like oh I just saw him he was
just he was giving somebody a wedding
story yeah yeah yeah yeah like so so
it's this Fame that's like uh it's it's
very different and I think that aspect
of it causes sometimes these you know
media conglomerates to like like they
should be winning all the comedy Emmys
and all that for sure their shows are
the biggest the funniest you know so so
uh but but listen you know I I I can
promise you that the Impractical Jokers
are doing very well yeah have you done
have you done the cruise yet I did the
cruise I did the cruise in February of
2020 when literally the same Cruise
right a boat that left the same time as
us from a couple of Bays down starting
covet they got locked on the boat in
whatever their destination was for three
weeks oh they were on the same day you
dodged a [ __ ] you dodged a covet
bullet geez yeah but but it was fun so I
did the last one uh I don't know if the
cruise industry's even coming back I
don't know if they're going to do
another one you know I've never been on
a cruise there's just something about
yeah it's just it's just to me it's like
yeah why would I go trap myself on a
boat for 600 for a week well it was
interesting because you know the the the
the rooms the or one of the rooms that I
was in had a Jeep had the boat's GPS in
it right one of the T and you went from
Miami to the Bahamas but that trip only
takes like six hours but you're in the
middle of the sea for three days so it
literally is just making circles and
going up and down and left and right for
a day I'm like this is so dumb you're
killing all these fish oh like this is
dumb and these people are just eating on
the buffet like they're just just
hoarding all this food yeah no it was it
was one of those things where I was like
you know of course happy to do it but I
was like one of those things I'm happy I
experienced it don't know that I'll
never take the wife and kids on one of
these no they don't want to go yeah no
they no that when we no no we I take
them to Puerto Rico and then that that's
fun the last time we went to Puerto Rico
I thought I was going to get sacrificed
hey guys we gotta stop the interview to
tell you about our good folks over at
bluechoo.com that's right listen you got
to go to Bluetooth right now sign up for
uh Bluetooth with the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month for
free Bluetooth the same active
ingredient as Viagra Ana Cialis but in a
chewable form that's right you pop the
blue shoe chew that thing wash it down
with your beverage of choice and then
get to work with that hard [ __ ] [ __ ]
of yours your dick is going to be harder
than trigonometry was in high school
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
[ __ ] raw like you know uh Ryu and
Street Fighter he'd be like and then he
does the [ __ ] this is gonna be
your dick it's gonna be like ryu's
[ __ ] uppercut you know what I'm
saying God bless whoever's on the
receiving end of that consensually of
course uh they're gonna thank you for
taking the blue shoe so go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
all right I'm talking free month right
to your doorstep Indiscreet packaging no
awkward doctors visits all right it's
all online you don't have to worry about
going and sitting in a waiting room and
be like hey Doc uh my dick I could use a
little a pep in my step and then it's
awkward you gotta look at this old [ __ ]
talking about your dick he might ask you
to pull it out who [ __ ] knows what's
going on at Bluetooth none of that's
happening bluetooth.com and they also
got the new brand new to a mint flavored
chewable which has vardinophil in it
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra and staxin which is a little
more potent a little more potent if you
need the extra on top of the extra you
know what I mean get the mint chewable
yeah your wife will thank you your
girlfriend no thank you your boyfriend
will thank you
whatever the [ __ ] you're [ __ ] I'll
thank you as long as it's legal all
right let's get back to the interview go
to bluetooth.com promo code bootleg
that's it I literally was like yo we are
in a Puerto Rican Village everyone's
looking at me like we've never seen a
gringo like who is this guy yeah there
were like holy because we went to uh her
family from out of sibo okay which is
like in the mountains yeah so it was
like there's no tourists there there
were like I was the white guy that was
that they were like what the [ __ ] are
you nobody spoke English or if they
spoke English but it was like they some
of the houses didn't have electricity
since the last hurricane I was like babe
can we just go back to uh San Juan yeah
I would just be asking everybody like
hey so you guys really don't pay taxes
huh yeah yeah nothing I was like Bernie
Bernie I just kept saying Pani
acaporia
like different foods was there any um
once you start to bring a guests on your
show was your wife like a little more
hesitant to have you have people just
pull up to your crib so what happened
was is we had great guests his name was
John a light he wrote a book uh uh um he
was like on a John Gotti's like henchman
right like beat people to death with a
baseball bat right at your house so and
I didn't think twice about it yeah I
literally and Jazz you know she could
hear from the kitchen like and he was
being hilarious I had like a lemon shirt
on he was like well [ __ ] a nice land I
should hit those Lemons with a bat you
know like just telling us like things
he's like yeah one time I was killing a
guy I was kind of his body I had to take
a [ __ ] I [ __ ] in the woods and she's
just like literally our baby was like
three months old she's like feeding the
baby and then like we're having fun I
thought it was great like you know pack
up whatever I'm like jazz I mean how
great was that pods gonna get a [ __ ]
million views I mean how great was that
she was like did you think that it was a
good idea to bring a man who's admitted
to multiple murders to our house with
our daughters did you think that that
was a good idea at all and I was like
yes for the podcast and she was like
wasn't smart she goes never ever bring a
murderer to this house again that's a
fair request I was like you know what
babe I understand I think that what you
say it is right I'm gonna sleep on the
couch tonight and good and she but when
she put it to me like that she's like
our daughters are six and one and you
have a murderer in their living room
yeah where they sit and sleep and did
you think about that at all this is our
home and then I was like I'll get a
podcast yeah now you get the studio now
from what I remember I listened to your
episode with with uh Rogan your dad was
kind of like a like a pretty tough guy
right one of those like vintage New York
tough guys yes back in the day now he's
got you know now he's on dialysis with
two fake knees uh but but but he's back
in the day
you know I think a lot of guys in you
know it's from the Bronx I think a lot
of guys in the 70s 80s even early 90s
got mixed up with those guys you know
gambling right and and running around
and it's just an easy way to make money
like hey you know you you work for this
family you know go pick up this gambling
debt that gambling debt so you get to
know those guys not that he was ever a
maid guy or whatever right but you get
to know those guys you get to know those
Circle you know those people was that
collected money yeah yeah yeah pretty
much like uh his job I would call like
it was it was like a different work
number every week and if somebody would
just be like accounting and it was
always like some guy some different guy
you know I I no idea like so he'd have
to go shake down the business owners
yeah I I guess yeah because that's the
thing with my dad is I never really
asked too many questions on what he did
but I just like would always get I would
always get like because my parents got
divorced right when I was very young
yeah and I would always get like kind of
hints of like oh my mom doesn't like
believe my dad or like my dad because
like I remember one time like being a
little kid and being like Dad like you
know like it's career day tomorrow like
what do you do for like work what's your
job again like my mom being like my mom
she was like making dinner she's like
I'd love to see what he says now you
know like she's like let's see what Tony
what [ __ ] accounting well no I
remember he said he goes I go I go he
works and he said he goes he goes oh oh
Chris I work for the banks and I was
like oh you oh you worked for the bank
so I went huh the banks and they just
kept like you know making the spaghetti
and I was like and I was like yeah she
was just you know I don't remember like
not like just like okay is that why your
mom divorced him well dude no my mom
said they my mom served divorce papers
to my dad when she was pregnant with me
because he gambled this was 1984 I was I
was born in 84. okay so the Jordan year
he was drafted in 84. bro 1984 there's a
book I forgot what it's I think it's
called Glory years it's about how Wild
the year 1984 was I haven't read it yet
but there's like a lot of [ __ ] that went
down in 1994. um but so 84 uh uh my dad
um you know bad Gambler whatever took
like eight thousand dollars of like my
of their like ten thousand dollar
savings and better than like the
Montreal Expos like some [ __ ] random
thing and they lost and then so and then
I think what happened was is my somebody
called my dad didn't pay up and somebody
called my mom at like whatever it is 10
p.m it was like where's the money I know
you're pregnant you don't want to fall
down a flight of stairs like [ __ ] like
that and then my mom took me to like
Lancaster Pennsylvania like we got it we
gotta get out of Dodge got out of Dodge
came back gave birth and then I think
that was like the beginning of the end
and then uh but but but my dad always
says he's like you know when you were
born like that was like that's when I
feel like I hit the lotto like that like
you and then he started to like slowly
get out of it all and now I mean I don't
know anything like about I have multiple
family members uh on my dad's side who
were like murdered and stuff like that's
like real on the nose mommy murdered it
like shot like shot and killed police
never investigated it so it's like you
know like sleep with the fishes
oh yeah so I'm like so that stuff I'm
like oh see that's the thing with like
with like organized crime and all that
like it's it's cool and romanticized in
the movies and it is it is I get why but
when it's actually in your family you're
like
who is like the closest relative to you
that you that passed my uh Uncle so my
my aunt's husband but I was again a
little kid but him and his son my cousin
would just murdered like shot to death
at work in Long Island uh uh New Jersey
yeah I do yeah then when you look it up
it's like that there was no leads no
nothing and then it's crazy my aunt got
um and this is like a a mafia thing my
aunt got I don't know for the amount of
time but like every month behind like
one of the plants give me money bag of
money because probably the family that
killed him are like well we got to take
care of the wife if we're gonna yeah say
them out see those guys see that's the
thing like the Mafia the Italian mafia
it I understand the extortion and and
the crimes I get it I get why it's bad I
really do but there is a little bit
there's a little code there's a little
bit of like well it's a little bit safer
when the mafia is around they're not
gonna here's the thing it's yes it sucks
I gotta pay this fee this extortion fee
that sucks but you know what no one's
ever gonna break into my business no
one's ever gonna hurt my kids because if
they do they're [ __ ] dead and they
will not mess with you unless you mess
with them at least the old guys are the
noob people you know I don't know but
the old guys my father always say the
only people you got to watch out for in
this world are Mafia wannabes the
wannabes are the guys who will hurt you
because they don't live by the code the
guys who buy the code you never see it
coming you just get one at the back of
the head but they would never touch you
unless you did something to them and
they would you know I remember being in
um uh uh Cross Bay Boulevard the Howard
Beach always would have a festival right
like a carnival every year and I
remember going there once with my dad
and John Gotti and his guys were handing
out free candy to all the kids I was
like this guy's [ __ ] like Jesus did
you get any candy from him of course wow
yeah no we were with all the kids gave
it to all the kids he was just John
Gotti you got some Gotti's candy
somebody Mafia candy yeah it was like a
big deal like a kids would there's a
million kids did he say hi to your dad
no he's like hey it's been a while good
to see you no but you know what's funny
it's he didn't say hi to my dad but when
John Gotti died his funeral was in
Queens and I remember my dad was like
you know uh I lived in Queens right and
my dad you know I was a teenager by then
so it's not like I knew his you know
whereabouts every second of the day but
but he called me he's like I'm in Queens
you want to get a slice of pizza I'll
meet you by your mother's house and I
was like oh cool and then I understand I
was like why are you in Queen's a guy a
friend died I went to their funeral and
I was like oh
because I know that but but I never
asked like but it kind of not it could
not it could have been coincidence
exactly if I'm you I'm like Dad yeah
you're on dialysis yeah you got two old
knees or new knees whatever yeah let's
peel back the onion give me some of
these stories I know I know let's do a
podcast yeah yeah no he wouldn't that's
the thing because he wouldn't say
because he's very much like I don't want
you near this right you know but it was
funny when I remember that day was like
I was at a friend's funeral I was like
oh John Gotti yeah yeah okay oh man
imagine it wasn't it was just like a
neighbor yeah you just came up with this
coincidence in your head none of it's
real he's never in the mafia it's okay
no no he actually worked for the banks
you know he genuinely works for Chase
yeah my mother he cheated on my mom yeah
that's why she just [ __ ] she just
she's just bitter yeah that's all it is
uh what do you got coming up uh
obviously you uh had special where she
come out earlier this year especially
Western on Netflix came out that's
that's still out there and I'm proud of
that one because that was all
self-produced by me that was Netflix had
actually said everybody had said no to
my special like of me did you already
get that made and then take it to them
pre no so what happened was is I was
before I made it I was trying to have
people come out watch my hour and this
and that and everyone was just passing
on me HBO said no Netflix or some of
them wouldn't even come out it's like no
I'm not looking for that yeah okay
they're like we don't want a straight
white male right in comedy at that point
fine I'm not complaining about it but
right just what it was right we'll find
another way no problem but so I got to a
point where I said you know what [ __ ]
what what am I even going after these
corporate corporations for my whole
mindset from day one like I said in the
beginning this podcast has been give it
to your fans so I said you know what I'm
gonna put this [ __ ] on YouTube I'm gonna
self-produce it didn't want my guy Mike
lab and the homeless pimp who does all
my podcasts I said he's going to direct
it film it we're doing it that way
whatever so it filmed it all these
companies had said no
and then my agent was like listen I
think this is a great special let me at
least just put this in Netflix's hands
now that the product is finished
and we'll see what they say day later
they call Netflix wants it so I said so
I get on the phone with Netflix you know
you have to talk to them they say Hey
you know we want it I said great I said
you guys can have it appreciate it but
you have to take it as is and they're
like well at the end of the special you
you [ __ ] on Netflix I was like you have
to take it as is or I'm just going to
put it on YouTube and they're like the
only thing we want is obviously to edit
out the Netflix stuff I said you have to
take it as is if you do not if if that's
edited out then I will put it on YouTube
I don't care I said I I respect Netflix
I really do I was like my kids [ __ ]
love cocoa but I I literally don't care
at all if my thing is on this platform
right it's for the fans so either keep
it in or I will put it on YouTube in a
week it doesn't matter to me and then
they were like okay let's check with the
high ups and then the high UPS didn't
give a [ __ ] they were like just put it
on as is then so so I was like so that's
what it is so if you watch my special
again I just I'm kind of like you know I
think it's for you guys but [ __ ] [ __ ]
Netflix but if you guys want to buy it
I'll sell it to you yeah you know like I
say that at the end and and it's in so
I'm proud of that and then the you know
the next special I'm gonna do another
special uh in about six to eight months
but the plan will be the same give it to
the people and you know
if somebody wants wants in they can get
in if not it's going straight to the
people hey we gotta stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our
partners at Odd Socks our presenting
sponsor here at the bootleg hit podcast
listen Christmas time is approaching
faster than you think I mean we're like
[ __ ] a month and a half away or some
[ __ ] whatever uh get some Odd Socks for
your folks go to oddsocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world that's
right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy
literally the most comfortable sock in
the world I'm holding the [ __ ] sock
right now you can save 20 off plus they
got boxers now baby all right go to Odd
Socks official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview the thing is is it it's like a
a metaphor for life too it's like
there's nothing there's nothing to get
and nobody can give you anything anymore
like they're especially in entertainment
like nobody can give you anything you
can only do it yourself and put it out
yourself there's people are like oh I
want to get something there's nothing to
get you have to you have to make it
happen and put it out that's this is the
only way like even now you know take
someone like like Andrew Schultz who's
made his whole career and living off
just putting his things out now the
movies and TV shows come to him because
there was nothing they could give him he
he had to do it and then they see oh we
want that yeah so so so
that's a mindset that I hope my
daughters don't have to do comedy but I
hope they if they're going to take
anything from me be like oh you know we
we have to create things and we have to
do things there's nobody's going to give
you anything right in this world you
gotta you gotta make it and then you
know let somebody you know buy it from
you uh last couple things give me your
all-time Mount Rushmore of Comedy Mount
Rushmore of Comedy
um Mount Rushmore of Bill Burr uh I like
Bill Burr Louis C.K yeah uh Dave
Chappelle and you know who is one of the
most underrated comics of not that he's
underrated he's wildly famous but people
don't know about his stand-up Jamie Foxx
oh yeah I might need security dude
that's one of my favorite stand-ups bro
that is that's a great special his I
believe that Jamie Foxx is the just if
we're just talking about Talent across
the board in the Arts he is the number
one most talented person I've ever seen
in my entire life yeah of my generation
he does uh high level acting high level
comedy high level music yep the only
other person who's in that conversation
I think is uh is Chris Brown yes well
and Justin Timberlake is is JT's up
there was very good on SNL and all that
and obviously you know acting but but
Chris Brown yeah very funny but uh you
know very talented but but for me I got
a mean punch mean Punch Yeah great boxer
Great boxer um the dance yeah can paint
I love it he can paint he's like he does
like full murals on walls and [ __ ]
really yeah he's autistic he can hoop
Kenny hoop he's like a really good
Hooper he's interested rap he can sing
his acting's okay Jamie though I think
does the most things at a high level
yeah Jamie Foxx to me it's just it's
just he's so talented it like it it
makes you want to like quit like where
you're like well I'll never be as good
as him but but but but but you know now
I'm just like yeah again I just what
about at this very moment who do you
think are the funniest comedians in the
world right now right now the funniest
comedians I like Shane Gillis he's
hilarious Shane Gillis I think makes me
laugh Mark Normand Mark Norman school
sam moral
um I die laughing at and um uh who else
uh Stavros halikis is a guy he's great
baby
um I love so bad for that guy every time
the Ravens lose he's like melts down on
[ __ ] Instagram I know
I know he can't get any more bald yeah
uh and then and then there's a guy who I
just I watch his stuff and I cry
laughing as a Kyle Dunnigan who makes
these unbelievable
um uh sketches
um and then uh yeah there's this kid
Eric dalessandro who makes these
sketches on Instagram that that very New
York base I I really like that but yeah
those you know and and because you know
it's hard with my peers and and stand up
that you know because like we're all
kind of not competing with each other
but we're it's tough to like get in a
zone that just breaks down where like we
can laugh because you know a comic peer
of mine will make a great joke and I'll
be like [ __ ] instead of laughing I'm
like why did I think of that yeah why
don't I have a premise like that it's
very difficult to separate it's like you
know an athlete watching another athlete
yeah they're admiring them but they're
also like yo I gotta step my game up
it's hard to just sit back and enjoy
um but yeah though I think those people
are you know they just make me laugh
Bobby Lee okay he's great die laughing
Anderson
Bobby Lee doesn't have a special
no yeah like there's a lot of people say
he just has been doing the same like
hour for like ever you know I I to be
fair I haven't seen Bobby Lee's most
recent stand up but the thing is every
time I see him it's just so over the top
funny that even if it was the same
material I don't notice I love the
podcast like talk about it tiger fella
yeah David tell us like that David tell
is another guy in the Mount Rushmore of
comics like David tell him Colin Quinn
right on the Mount Rushmore of comics to
me as well but atel only has one or two
specials and Colin has uh um uh like one
man shows but only one or two actual
songs shows about history that are
brilliant they're great but it's just
one man show so so you know it's this
interesting thing where like sometimes
people don't put out a whole you know a
whole bunch of stuff that's that's fair
uh last thing you went on Rogan
obviously that seems to be kind of like
a turning point for every comedian like
once you get the invite to Austin yeah
and you go down there and you see Joe
did you first of all how was the
experience did he give you any game and
uh did you notice kind of things uptick
afterwards you know it's getting on
Rogan when I did so so it's fine it's
fantastic to to do Rogan I'm always do
it but it's weird that like you know
first of all when I met him it it was
cool because you know he he asked you
know me to come on which is different
when you ask them when they ask you come
on that's the way you want it of course
you know he showed me his whole facility
and he's like kicking he's like you know
he's like a a great like boxer and
kickboxer he's like kicking this [ __ ]
heavy bag like I'm like this guy gonna
kick myself on the show I'm like this is
I'm intimidated you know she's like this
is my cryo chamber I'm like are we gonna
go in it or do you want to do the Pod
like it was like two hours of like this
is what I did it was the tour it was
like yeah I'm a man's man yeah which I
was like all right I had like on a
flowered shirt I was like well I I don't
know yeah I'm gay and and and
um and it's interesting you know I did
the show
I did you know you know to do I did like
three and a half hours with him like the
longest I ever do on a podcast is like
an hour because like what what can you
even talk about but for him it's like
he's so good at like just keeping the
convo going like you'll say something
and then he's because he's listening
right the thing is is like you're very
good at it too like you're just like
listening you're not worried about like
what he's going to say like he's like
I'm just listening to you right and then
going off you it's very natural very
calming
um but you know it's it's weird is that
you know by the time I got to do Joe
Rogan
um you know I had had to get my fans
kind of
the hard way and kind of get them one by
one by one so I don't know that too many
people heard me on Joe Rogan that didn't
already kind of make a decision on me
whether they liked me or not maybe I was
able to get some people who didn't
initially like me to like me uh and
follow but I didn't notice my followers
go up or my ticket numbers really I
didn't notice it too much it kind of
stayed where it's at
um because I think that you know I was
doing all the orbital podcasts I was
doing through doing everything during
Christ I was doing so all those people
that listened to Rogan they listen to
these other guys too so they heard me on
that
um and by the you know it sounded like
you were like like new to his audience
at that point yeah I mean I'm definitely
was new to some people of course um but
also the other thing with Joe is he puts
out so much content and I understand why
that you get swallowed up very easily in
the algorithm so it's like I was you had
an opportunity to listen to my three and
a half hours for about two days yeah and
then somebody else five hour episode
came up so so it's very difficult to to
listen to it all I watched the whole
thing where I always listen to it I
listened to it it was good man there you
go it's like like the story about your
pops like I think he was going to see
was it your principal at your school
yeah yeah that's the thing if you Google
Chris DiStefano 911 story it's like the
most viral thing I've ever done I've did
a stand-up bit about my time on 9 11.
you can check it out but it's funny like
people come up to the streams like
you're the 911 guy right and I'm like
yeah yeah but then people don't know
what I'm talking about like what are you
saying you're the 911 guy it was you
yeah it was you Tower seven was you I'm
Bin Laden in white face there it is hey
willick I appreciate you coming through
man and making time I know you got your
family appreciate it my man boom